c'est le patron du réseau de téléphonie
orange qui a délivré l'information selon
laquelle plus d'un million de personnes
auraient quitté le grand paris le jour
de la noce du confinement imposée par le
gouvernement une fuite massive des
parisiens en région dans leurs familles
ou dans leur résidence secondaire pour
tenter de vivre un confinement en plein
air certaines célébrités n'hésitent pas
à partager ces moments avec leurs
communautés à l'image de sophie davant
qui privé de ses émissions sur france 2
a décidé de profiter de la mer cauet de
son côté continue chaque jour ses
émissions sur nrj mais en direct depuis
le touquet où l'animateur a depuis
plusieurs années une résidence
secondaire
estelle denis quant à elle s'est
réfugiée en bretagne où elle profite du
soleil pour se maintenir en forme
même chose pour l'ex miss france laury
thilleman qui profitent du grand air
avec son chien si certains trouvent ses
photos et ses publications indigne
donnant un mauvais exemple de
comportement citoyen d'autres au
contraire trouvent que ces personnalités
ont tout à fait le droit d'habiter dans
la résidence de leur choix confinement
ou non alors c'est vrai que vous bernard
montiel que cette partie au dans votre
résidence du pilat vous avez rejoint le
prix la survie mais c'est à dire je suis
je suis bordelais et j'ai cette maison
depuis plus de trente ans et c'est ma
résidence principale ou je vais
régulièrement dans ce rôle et j'ai eu
tu comprends les gens qui critiquent non
je ne comprends pas qu'ils critiquent
vous savez je me suis amusé à envoyer
quelques images parce qu'on avait droit
à quelques ballades même à sortir un peu
j'ai fait des images de la mer des
promenades des rues désertes etc
certains me l'ont reproché mais très peu
d'autres surtout mon dieu merci ça nous
permet de nous évader de voir autre
chose voilà alors il ya toujours les
pour et les contre et je m'en fous
d'aidé contre d'ailleurs moi je garde
que le meilleur les gens qui trouvent
que ces déplacés gilles verdez
chaussures voilà oui ça ne me gêne pas
qu'il soit parti mais ce qui me gêne
c'est que toutes ces stars poste des
photos de belles places de beaux
paysages concours me marier comme pour
nous narguer et je veux mais je vous le
dise le demande on tienne le c'est
ridicule a touché un proche allié
ils nous narguent et ça c'est pas bien
je trouve que sa méprise les gens qui
sont restés dans leur ville moi
personnellement je n'aurais pas quitter
ma ville voilà mais on peut le faire
moi je suis pas riche reste à paris mais
ce que fait mon cal avec ses photos
arrête de poster des photos non ce que
leur reproche les gens je vous le dis
c'est les personnalités qui disent
rester chez vous alors qu'elles se sont
barrés à la campagne oui oui c'est ça en
fait que disent les gens sur twitter à
dix ils nous disent rester chez vous et
eux bail ce bar voilà donc c'est ça qui
gêne leur enseigner quoi je pense que
chacun est libre et fait ce qu'il veut
mais c'est vrai que ça peut être très
angoissant quand vous êtes enfermé dans
un petit appartement et vous voyez des
gens qui ont d'autres choses
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya un juste dosage
je pense qu'ils vont pas trop montrer
quand on a des choses que les autres ne
peuvent pas avoir vraiment c'est
vraiment un long de faire quand vous
êtes avec des enfants enfermés avec des
enfants petit vous pouvez pas sortir
c'est la galère et c'est vrai que vous
vous dites arrêtés nous dit rester chez
nous parce que moi si j'avais un jardin
si j'avais une plage à côté bien sûr que
je resterai chez moi donc je pense qu'il
faut faire attention dans son poste on
ne pas monter la pression
tout ça n'est pas le débat le débat
s'est tous ces gens qui vous disent
rester chez vous et on les voit se
s'être bari 2-2 des grandes des grandes
villes bah castaldi non mais d'abord il
avait le temps il vous rappelle que ya
eu il ya eu 24 heures pour quitter
londres ont été pour choisir son
confinement
on va pas et hypocrite on sait très bien
que les gens qui ont qui ont réussi qui
ont de l'argent ils ont des maisons
secondaires et qui sont dedans kiwi le
problème tient c'est un faux débat
tétouan avec lesquels vous dit ça pour
bernard montiel canet qui a pris
beaucoup d'argent en animant un mondial
surnommé beau nom mais non mais on se
doute bien que non mais je suis dit non
mais justement c'est ce que je te jure
train de te défendre
évidemment que les gens qui ont la
chance d'avoir une deuxième maison est
plutôt au soleil à la mer ou à la
campagne évidemment qu'ils y vont par
exemple m castaldi dans l'exemple
atteint cela dit par exemple avec tout
le succès qu'il a eu il n'a pas pu
acheter une deuxième maison mais lui en
fait faut il à hilla il a beaucoup
divorcer voilà chacun a fait des
investissements ce qui l'a vu lui un
mois j'ai pu la maison c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave et après tu as des
essais mais l'essentiel mais voilà et
c'est le fait d'être effectivement et
quand ton post est bien honnêtement je
connais beaucoup de gens qui postent
c'est plutôt sympa de montrer d'autres
choses que voilà ça fait rire les gens
alors on ya droit
chaud oui mais le régime algérien non
mais le problème ce sont les gens qui
bougent maintenant en fait maintenant on
sait que le foyer infectieux est
principalement à paris et l'île de
france et tous les gens qui bougent par
exemple qui vont à bordeaux qui vont à
biarritz ou qui vont en normandie emmène
le virus avec eux donc quand on effectue
membres de son parti dans les 24 heures
attribut il n'y a pas de problème c'est
aujourd'hui les gens qui bougent je
pense qu'ils posent un problème bernard
montiel cyril oui
non je voulais simplement précisé moi je
suis parti tout de suite après le
dernier enregistrement de touche pas à
mon poste le vendredi dont j'étais pour
aller au vote pour aller voter à
bordeaux le 20 ou non que c'était bien
avant le confinement total d'un donc
voilà pour la veille à bordeaux et quand
j'ai su que j'avais lu tpm hyères fm
bien dit oui je vivais j'aurais chez moi
et bart ouattara mais merci alors eric
naulleau il disait tout à l'heure qu'il
s'agissait d'un virus égalitaire ben non
c'est un virus très inégalitaire parce
qu'il révèle les fractures sociales i
hereby révèle une france à deux vitesses
et à ceux qui peuvent échapper aux
coronavirus et ceux qui ne peuvent pas y
échapper ce sont les goulots en première
ligne voilà et le scandale il
il est social maintenant les gens qui
ont le choix entre deux maisons
vous pouvez faire un sondage si on n'est
pas propre hypocrite on va choisir le
conflit millénaire mais c'est pas ça le
scandale le véritable scandale ce qui
est autant de différences sociales entre
les gens et des gens qui soit exposé au
virus ne peuvent pas y échapper ces deux
caissières si vous êtes infirmières si
vous êtes quoi lourdes et ses chauffeurs
de deux couleurs voilà où elle s'en va
après c'est vraiment on n'a pas besoin
de ce genre de querelles en plus de tous
les problèmes que l'on reproche de
coronado vraiment gérer mais il a tout
territoire
ça c'est qu'on n'est pas égalitaire face
à ce virus
erika tour à tout bien résumé après
c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut tomber sur
les gens pour la chance d'avoir une
maison avec un jardin c'est humain de
vouloir se dire tout ce qu'on veut être
pour fille née pendant quarante
cinquante fois je valais dans mon jardin
les quatre ont assité estelle denis elle
va en bretagne toute l'année montiel il
va à l'adulte
il a tout à neko et la maison de fitch
il bien sûr ça parce qu'il ya compte il
ya quand les autres sont leurs vidéos
alors peut-être me peut-être qu'ils
peuvent se passer de faire des vidéos
pour entre guillemets marquer mais faut
pas faux pas de gêne comme ça ils font
chacun
chacun doit rester dans son confinement
là où il est et les gens il y en a plein
qui sont les gens qui savent très bien
que quand on m'a dit benjamin pas et
hypocrite on sait très bien qu'ils ont
tous des baraques
bah oui je suis a bien dit il faut
partir maintenant maintenant il faut
taper sur celui qui part maintenant tu
les fais partie avançait très bien on va
voir on va voir le sondage twitter les
cherry sur ce sujet on y va ça chez à la
base mon chéri voilà qui est avec moi
58%
oui et non à 42% voiliers ou pas gala
58% qui comprennent les critiques autour
des stars ayant quitté paris voisins
sont pas tant ils sont pas d'accord avec
vous ils sont plutôt d'accord avec
gilles verdez